do you think there'll ever be a time you
know all these everybody loves reunions
do you think there'll be a time where
all eight of you will get back together
again
i mean
maybe yeah they're i mean it's always
what's going on
yeah i mean there's always a possibility
i mean the door's not shut between us so
like we still talk about it
so i mean maybe
john would you be down for one of those
see i asked about this and i wanted this
like to do a reunion kind of thing
but um i got shot down amongst uh
kate and and
a couple other uh siblings
but it's always i always like initiate
initiate
um
maybe not a tv reunion but maybe
something else but would you do a tv
reunion oh absolutely yeah yeah bring
everybody together and sit down just
hash it out talk about whatever the kids
are 18 now they can make their choices
the ones you want to come on can come on
right yeah they can sign their do
whatever they want you're ready for that
oh yeah
because i know the truth what is the one
thing that you would want people to know
i the truth like i know the truth like
what's the one thing you'd want people
to know why did the divorce happen
why did the divorce happen
who left who why did the divorce happen
why did the divorce happen yeah because
a certain person left me we're having a
good time and i know
we need to do this for our marriage i
think too many people don't
john do you think back to those times
you remember some of the good times oh
yeah there were some good times i mean
in the early seasons it was just like
survival mode
like straight survival mode
because in the early like the first
second and third like i was going to
work
and then coming home and filming
and interviewing on weekends and like
like kind of just working like a hundred
hours a week
and then like you know and then we had
to do morning america and all the media
and like
tea and all this stuff so
that was just like it just went by so
fast do you remember when you realized
that you had a hit on your hands that
like america loved your family i guess
when we moved from discovery health to
tlc that's when it kind of all hit hit
us and then
when you're like taking your eight kids
through new york city and people are
like
and then you're like what am i doing
or you're in rockefeller center you're
like what am i doing and then people are
like then the paparazzi are coming and
you're like
this is so strange and then you come
back to your hometown and then you
realize
when you go to the mall or something
like that in rural pennsylvania
people are taking pictures of them
that's when they kind of all hit
life with two six year olds and six
three year olds gets pretty hectic
i gotta go and although the stress of
having two sets of multiples doesn't
always bring out the best in us
we're a family we're in this together
it might be a crazy life
but it's our life
do you ever watch the old episodes and
when you're watching what do you think i
mean if i could i would they're like
thirty dollars a season
come on you guys don't have the whole
entire like no library
they're downloads
wow
so it's like three bucks an episode yeah
so have you have you seen you've seen
some i've seen some yes yeah what did
you think
um
there it's
cool to watch yourself when you're like
little because you know everyone has
like the home videos and everything and
the pictures but i get to watch like
all these
all these things that we did and it's
fun like it's cool to see
me and my siblings like
interact with each other like when we
were little and you get to like watch
and see the little things that like not
everyone remembers
being 18 also means that
you now
get all that money that you earned as a
kid on tv
i do i mean i don't know how much it is
but i'm really hoping that i can use it
to pay for my future college plans
so you're gonna put yours to good use oh
yeah i've always said like when i do get
the money that i'm gonna use it to pay
for my college wow and you also got a
message from your mom today i did she
did test send me a text what did she say
she just you know wished me happy
birthday you know told me she loved me
it was great like an average birthday
text what has it been like living with
your dad and why did you choose to live
with your daughter
i chose to live with my dad um
i i feel like i just made the choice for
myself i've always been closer to my dad
and we've always had a strong good
relationship
and
it was a
choice kind of of it's a lot growing up
in a very busy household with lots of
kids and there's not very a one-on-one
relationship or attention that you have
with a parent
i felt like my dad gave me that
attention and
feeling like i had a good solid
relationship with
a parent so that must have been a hard
decision
take us inside the decision that you say
i'm going to stay in pennsylvania i want
to stay with my dad
um it was a difficult decision leaving
my siblings i did not want to you know
be separated from them or even like live
in a different household than them
communication with my other children
meaning the children that live with kate
is very difficult because i don't have
an open relationship with them but she
has a really good relationship with the
other kids i have been alienated
from those children will you try to
reach out to them now
i
i don't have and i don't have any lines
to open up to them it will be better if
they try to reach out to me if they have
my number she has the that person said
that's correct she has the number you
won't get the number for you
i do but i never wanted to put the
pressure on hannah
to reach out because i didn't want to
you know what i'm saying get the number
from hannah and you reach oh i've done
that before but i don't want to put the
pressure on her
to break down the relationship between
her and her siblings saying you know i
like using her
to get to the other kids and you know
people are what you'll say but all all
you have to do is give them the phone
number oh well i've already done that
i've already texted them before and i've
texted manny and kara and haven't done
that but i've never gotten a response
i've texted manny and carol on their
birthdays memory out of response as a
dad being a dad that has that sucks
that's got a sense horrible yes do you
miss them oh of course i miss them
that's why i post things on my instagram
like throwback you know
tbd so
it's it
it's bittersweet but you know
her and colin live with me so i kind of
just focus on them and whatever happens
but now the others for being adults
maybe they'll realize what the truth is
and what has transpired
and
maturity sets in or they'll ask hannah
or ask colin you know what is the truth
or what has happened
if you could say something decay today
what would you say a lot you own the
truth own it
what's what's the point you don't have a
show anymore so you might as well tell
the truth
you're not protecting a network this
reunion would be incredible yeah that's
what i mean i'd just be like it would be
incredible
yeah no just be like
[Music]
you